[Music]
i'm
so excited jubilee is bank
hell yeah they tested everyone so they
can get them back in the room
ranking women by attractiveness five
guys
versus five girls oh my god so awkward
we're gonna have to rate yeah i can't
wait
this is amazing let's do this
stay safe thank you should we just like
close our eyes and like scoot to where
we thought oh my god
how are we not gonna bump into each
other did anyone take this into
consideration
we brought five women together rank
themselves based on their attractiveness
oh okay
that feels like a weird power thing
that's an interesting dynamic
you're not just rating yourself you're
also putting yourself in a place
right we also invited firemen to watch
and rearrange the ranking what
based on how they view the
attractiveness
oh this is funny i like this i got a
letter in the post
hmm what is this do i see more
threatening with the mustache
today's sponsor comes from display
should i have already done this no
because actually one of the really cool
things about
display is the fact that you can order a
ton of them and the packaging is still
so small
if you order usually prints online
they're freaking massive and it's so
annoying
so what this display i'll tell you it's
metal prints
we have a city to burn cyberpunk
anyone you can remind yourself every day
that the game is not out yet
this one's actually cool each plate is
manufactured individually by display
team using handcrafting techniques to
give it an absolute unique character
that's cool so this one is uh
fraying with this texture this is
probably the one i'll hang up actually
yeah they're official partners with
cyberpunk which is why they sent me
oh cool actually this can you tell it's
like a
wooden type of frame let's see official
partner with marvel
dc star wars cyberpunk and more if you
go to their website they have prints of
a ton of cool stuff
they have one million unique displays so
anything you like
they have a lot of minimalist stuff i
actually got
a that's the one i got it's pretty cool
honestly at first i was a little
skeptical but the quality is amazing
and they're very easy to hang got one in
japan because
yeah they're smaller because they're
thin
they're easy to hang great quality
prints and the best part you can change
them so let me show you
i was supposed to show you guys how you
put it on the wall but i forgot to
record
it's super simple all right so
i did it so quick i didn't even realize
uh you wipe down the surface
bing bong bing bong you put this
protective leaf you put the magnet
and that's it no screws no nothing and
the best part about it which i love
any height anything boom done done so
uh i'm already tired all day let me
change it
how cool is that i'm genuinely impressed
it's so dope
so cool all right so there you have it
i'm genuinely impressed i wasn't sure
what to expect
first i thought i'm never going to need
this many designs
obviously i have one wall but the fact
that you can change them so easy
totally makes it worth it so if you buy
right now the offer is one to two pla
displays you get 33 off if you enter
the link in the description display.com
pewdiepunk
including official cyberpunk 2077
designs
show your gamer cry about the game not
being out and stuff
but if you get three or more displays
40 off that's a great price that's a
great deal
cool sponsor i like it check it out
display.com beautypunk thank you
i feel like women have way different
tastes okay yes i'm gonna speak for
entire gender here yes
that i am not part of they do okay
i know if myself will like a girl
i tried to give it some thought and they
did not come out like i know
girls look at other girls that they
think is pretty
but i can tell yes sure they are maybe
no they're not the only pretty one is
martial there's no other girls but
there's certain girls that girls like
right that's a thing right
can i say that at least thank you so i i
got a feeling there's going to be
different results
can we say like what we do or like you
are
so i'm a dancer i'm very physical i use
my body a lot i love baking cakes i
always just like shove baked goods on my
friends
i teach she's the obnoxious one i got it
you're supposed to rank each other based
on attractiveness connecting to young
kids
i do mostly musical theater don't sold
this with
filthy personalities yeah because i'm a
weenie i know
um but i'm single as all heck hey i
am a journalism major i'm also a student
i'm double majoring in psychology and
criminal justice
i'm also an actress i love to travel
i've been to india five times
okay damn do this should we rank herself
should we just like close our eyes and
like scoot to where we think we should
be
i can't imagine taking part in that and
being like even if i thought i was the
most attractive one i can't imagine just
going
bam yeah it's me right how do you bait
i i think that's very smart
i feel like my personality is really
attractive my looks
i feel like i'm like okay like i don't
think anyone would look at me and be
like
oh i'm nervous how are we not gonna bump
into each other did anyone take this
okay she went off right away she's sorry
we're all so humble we're like i mean
we're all so
people don't know like which one is the
number
the girl who i found most attractive was
jordan she has a great
personality and she's confident though
all right i guess i guess they get to
judge my personality that's good oh see
i thought this is
[Laughter]
impression and attraction to the person
i'm just gonna put it out there just
saying
just so we do it one two three four what
damn
she's so wrong though
[Music]
oh sorry one
two three four one two three
four got it um one two three four
okay uh one two three four are they
remembering it so they
can judge base up or down or what are
they doing
okay i'll be two because i got all four
twos okay i think i got three four the
most
so i'll stick in that window depending
on the other person's they were
attractive okay that makes sense i saw
on the other girls that i didn't see
myself and hence i would have put them
higher as well
over me so people like she's so sweet
she's so funny she look
but like i wouldn't date her i guess
i'll be one
okay okay this is so awkward our women
have to be competitive about
attractiveness right
is that a yes yes i'm judging an entire
gen
a little bit come on come on come back
come on come you it's okay
it's all right you can say it you you're
a little competitive
i get it so am i so does that make me a
three
okay yeah i'll just stay here yeah
nobody really wanted to be lost and i
could kind of
feel that vibe so i was just like you
know it's fine
she took one for the team nice nobody is
a 5 really
i mean come on come on really out of all
these she's last
i'm not attracted to any one of these
okay at all nothing
build nothing i will go one two
three four five that's my
just from that's my rating yeah
where do you think you would fit
yourself in this one then uh well i mean
i don't know because i feel like
personality is a big thing
yeah yeah she's a woman oh by far oh two
two
three one what happened there
i would say three and then four three
not saying you don't have a personality
but i'm like
oh i'm five again i think we just put it
out
that's good job ladies you did you
i think her in the middle makes sense
but this is all
this is all wrong that's all wrong
i can't wait to see this
so are we gonna arrange in front of them
i want them to do it on the guys too
that'd be way easier to talk about as
well
do you want to start it all
over there
and you over there
like just shift down i think michelle is
attractive
how she looked how she carried herself
and it just seems like someone that's
going to live an exciting life i guess
you could say or that you could have
like a deep conversation with
exciting life i mean he's not wrong she
went to india five times
to be fair he did judge correctly could
you switch with her
i forgot they can't even hear me
okay well what would you switch i
switched her and her
yep uh it's just they were so content
catastrophically
wrong i had it's funny oh those two okay
all right
i love this this is amazing
you did it correct she kind of looks
like kristen bell
and i where's kirsten bell that's it
she's
she's a girl that maybe other girls like
right
that's what i meant that's perfect i
really like christmas all right
what the [ __ ] that you ruined my whole
theory god damn it i
put her in her in on the one or two
position and i kind of like her vibe
i think her whole aesthetic is very nice
so for me it's either one or two
appear i think that maria was the most
attractive for me
it was just like her whole vibe and like
i liked how her hair was how her makeup
was done
like she looked very nice are we content
with five being five
i'm not where do you currently walk yeah
i'm curious wait three
five goes up she should be a four
because it's like meeting the middle i
think
how do you pick the last one that feels
awful
i couldn't do this i mean i am i am i
already did it
sorry maybe but not in person we're
gonna get
ripped a new one here guys are not
afraid to be more blunt
they were straight up hey you're
attractive you're attractive you're not
but girls were like i don't want to be
rude you know we're all beautiful in our
own way
well you don't know that i feel bad
to be to be fair here sure uh there's
different
initial reaction on looks but also i
think the way someone looks
if it's not typically this standard of
society it could still really if they
have the right personality it could
really complement their looks you know
what i'm trying to say
trying to be nice i don't think it came
across okay
yeah i yeah i think you got it guys did
it
so interesting why did they put her last
wow
this is so interesting isn't it how
different
the girls and the boys did it i don't i
almost don't want them to rank
themselves it was interesting to say but
i almost want five girls to come in and
rank
them right jubilee can you do that
that'd be great that'd be super
interesting
so like impartial group of women comes
in and raped them
the way the guys were ranking the girls
i actually think we were doing it mostly
by personality
but they didn't speak you couldn't
talk to them what do you say
did i hear that right i actually think
we were doing it mostly by personality
i would
what what are you that's the opposite of
what you did i don't think you
understand what you were there for
well i was at five and now i'm here so
i'm like
thank you i don't know it's very
interesting i feel i did think coming
into this like
cultural stereotypes would be a factor
them making me first kind of
shot that down i guess because i didn't
think they would choose like an asian
girl first
wow so her ideas on her race holding her
back was completely
just in her head that's interesting
there was no chance for me
i was yeah there was no chance there me
being
hey different strokes for different
folks everybody beautiful on the inside
inside is that in beauty of
only black girl like i knew that i
wouldn't really rank
high because american beauty standards
versus
no come on the other ones have a better
face
there's nothing new it's different the
guys that i
interact with they socialize more with
black women and they think
more black women are attractive i think
that the guys
ranked the woman from appearance more
than
the most attractive personality in the
world most of the time
wow i think because the asian girl
looked more natural
she looked all pumped up you know she
has that
more stereotypical like she she even
said herself like yeah i'm the british
usually prettiest girl in the room me
being the only black girl like
i knew that i wouldn't really rank
because american beauty standards versus
what people see people of color
it's different yeah i mean i guess they
have a point too
a standard of beauty if you go back in
history it's so different
then again the greeks did find the
perfect body
of of humankind even though i have my
days where i'm like oh
you're not really that cute in days
where i'm like oh you like
you i would say
i wouldn't change i wouldn't change
good for you nice yeah i feel similar to
her actually
exactly verbatim
i feel like he would give you flowers
oh they're doing them next hell yeah i'm
excited for that
cool thanks for watching jubilee thanks
for being here i love your channel
black guy we were doing them mostly by
personality the girls we were earmuffs
and said nothing yeah
i hate this i don't feel like anything's
constructive gain out of it beauty is
different to everyone
no i think it's interesting to see how
women and and men look at each other
differently
and have different ideas of beauty
because that was very clear
from the ranking so that was constructed
my feelings would get so hard if i did
this just know that you're a piece of
[ __ ] and you'll never be disappointed
how people perceive you
all right that's it thanks for watching
look at the graph subscribe it's free
see you guys next week brofist we've
hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most
relevant of games we looked far and wide
to bring you the most up-to-date and
interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings